here are this week's top movies I think  I know when my dad went that's right in  the middle of the devil sea in Tomb  Raider a fiercely independent woman  faces her destiny when she embarks on a  far-flung adventure to find her father  done living in a world where I don't get  to be Who I am  I deserve a great love story in love  Simon 18 struggles with romance and  coming up it's nice to know there's  another guy at school with the same  secret when did you first realize life  nowhere because you chase some stupid  grin I can only imagine the challenging  true life drama between a father and son  that inspired a popular song is exam I  wrote this song from my dad see what's  hot in theaters with this week's fantasy  patient so what's your weekend ticket  going to be let us know by commenting  see you next time on weekend ticket  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]